من مسار الى اخر سرعه على ما يتطور
التصعيد الامريكي الروسي على خلفيه الحرب
الاوكرانيه اخرها تصعيد معركه الجواسيس
الموضوع هنا يتعلق باعتقال موسكو لمراسل
صحيفه
بتهمه التجسس هذا ما اعلن عنه جهاز الامن
الفيدرالي الروسي الذي كشف ان جيشكوفيتش
جمع معلومات تشكل سرا من اسرار الدوله حول
انشطه احدى المؤسسات العسكريه الروسيه
وذلك تنفيذا لتعليمات امريكيه وفقا
للاتهام الروسي اتهامات لم تتاخر الصحيفه
الامريكيه في نفيها جمله وتفصيلا داعيه
الى الافراج الفوري عن مراسلها ومعلنه في
الوقت نفسه تضمنها معه ومع عائلته حرب
التفريحات تواصلت على خلفيه هذا الاعتقال
حيث ردت المتحدثه باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الروسيه ماريا زخاروبا بالقول ان الكثير
من الاجانب يستغلون وضعهم كمراسلين
للتغطيه على انشطه غير صحفيه وهو الحال
بالنسبه لمراسل